o foco é o funk é cultura cultura de
culto cristão da facom derrotou o
[Música]
uma floresta
run to aí alguém falou tem alguém aí fui
porque esta casa está sem luxo alô van
[Música]
alguém falou primeiro lance everton não
[Aplausos]
[Música]
não não não
por isso foi bem duro
[Música]
num fax uma faca uma faca ou gente que
não seja eu quero só você é só vocês
algo ou alguém aí que eu tenho que fazer
é encontrar achava ram que encontra sob
controle devem compor a chapa encontra a
chave só em contração
a comida foi dessa comida que deixava
[Música]
a gente tem muita merda aqui havia
qualquer coisa que acontecer encontra
encontrar rui abrir a porta
dois apostadores da ordem
alô
por exemplo uma busca na liga dos
campeões e se deus quiser eu achava que
uma dessas portas tenho quase a certeza
neste momento estão em aquecimento aqui
você presta é para esta festa é muito
bacana local que isto precisa de bateria
com pessoal
[Música]
as pessoas acha alguém encontrar o
cartão de memória com ficheiros secretos
ok ok ok ok uma casa de banho tentarem
alguma margem para alguma marca de
certeza que tentarem alguma maneira que
foi
alô
cercado por floresta
o túnel estão aqui têm um cantar o que
está em questão o que vai contra
encontra aí encontrar um leitor de
cartões para aceder ao chefe
agora o ataque porque estou acaba por um
leitor de cartões têm que estar aqui
sentado aqui perto e tentar aqui muito
perto do hotel em ambas parou em baixo
porque os alunos
os amigos o fim de adaptar logo não se
mexer ministro falou em outro andar lá
em cima não vou lá e não vou lá não vou
lá forte de cheque não vou lá o eleitor
precisa do vetor da capital também fala
da bateria em busca
alô pessoal da casa é multicultural
carga está assombrada está assombrada
estação para estação brás
[Música]
a torcida precisa ter calma calma não
acontecer o que tem aqui o que é isto
a câmera tem qualquer coisa eu saí têm
qualquer coisa lei leitor de cartões
o encontro enquanto o que é isso mesmo
lopo coisa que eu fique calma vai
encontrar um pc para ler os arquivos
secretos que eu encontrei um psicólogo e
um pincel ligado ao ps ligatudo cirurgia
e meu estatuto de energia explica que
outra porta
[Música]
alguém aí eu pensei que liga a liga não
o fato de ligar tá tudo desligado meu
café da manhã em uma casa da mãe
aqui o teu porto aposta agora é hora de
botar a faca invadiu a área e chutou
forte
não não tenho uma casa
o sporting
o caju castanha que isto é tudo
[Música]
eu
não percebo tanto quanto me senti mal
[Música]
está posta no modo a que quem atirou de
fora que eu to aqui tem de ficar nada
não aproveitava
[Música]
a resposta é não